she 20 years old 22 years old or
something she's just a kid I I I've said
a lot of bad things about her lately
because she put herself in a position
where I need to publicly oppose her but
at the end of the day on a human level I
have a lot of sympathy for dumb kids
being dumb kids for sure you but I I I
just got to say I I got to push back we
we got to stop calling 22y olds children
no you know I actually appreciate you
calling me out on this I I went on at
length about this uh publicly not two
weeks ago that we infantilize adults by
calling them kids right is Young and
she's particularly young in the way that
our culture measures age today and so I
have some sympathy for her but you're
right she is no kid she's an adult she
has agency she's responsible for her
actions and I I take that rebuke